The first optimizations we
do are easy to implement and
make our code load faster.
We first glue our CSS and JavaScript
files together through concatenation,
then crunch them with a minifile.
In previous lessons,
we applied a couple tasks to our CSS.
But this time it's
mostly about JavaScript.
I say mostly because these
topics still apply to CSS.
It's simply that we're
already mostly covered.
Sass does both concatenation and
minification for you.
Manual concatenation isn't necessary,
because you can simply include
a single Sass file in your HTML.
Then use the import directive in
your Sass to input other files
into your base file.
When the Sass compiler
processes the Sass into CSS,
it will automatically inline those
inputs and generate one big CSS file.
A minification is just an optional way.
Just modify the Sass pipe slightly and
add outputStyle: 'compressed' as config,
which will produce
a nicely compressed file.